you say you were here with hours before
before you did an incredible Chewbacca
but I'm told you also do a Jar Jar Binks
[Music]
[Applause]
I think everyone doesn't impress no
Christopher Walken because he's such an
easy kind of you know I feel like what
this show needs is more cowbell depends
on what you like me to say basically
there's no punctuation comes out of my
mouth sometimes if you want me to talk I
just whatever comes into my head and say
I don't know when or what it's gonna be
[Applause]
[Laughter]
examina guy if i do the characters you
do you do Peter Brian Stewie quagmire
and then a smattering of others
okay and are they all based on people or
you just there they come from various
places Peter I knew a thousand Peter
Griffin's growing up in New England guys
who would not think before they spoke
like ever no self editing mechanism
everything it's coming out here with no
gateway when you're doing because you
know those characters are in scenes
together yeah do you do one line after
the other do you all do all one and then
go back do the other one when I do a
table read yeah I have to jump back and
forth right okay how much going on hello
sad man doing away
[Laughter]
I was just telling a story about
midnight in Paris the Woody Allen film I
was in and how I never had the whole
script tonight and I thought it was set
in the 20s and I turned up and I bombed
it Owen Wilson who didn't look like he
was in the 20s at all and and I said to
him I said so wait how and who you
playing cuz I'm playing f scott
Fitzgerald and I know Corey Stoll is
playing Ernest Hemingway and we're all
playing figures of history and he went
there was a director Joel Schumacher's
very funny man very tall very sort of
eccentric and he would direct with a
speaker and with a microphone and a
speaker usually directors will come up
and say hey yeah okay okay and you'd
hear this female humming boys and I
bolted into this suit I can't move and
he would literally go and he would
direct you like as if you would have
some emotional scene here we go
okay people all right George you know
your parents are dad you have nothing to
live for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
did you do a Liam oh he's not here
damn I should have asked you before do
we in Paisley whereas nine
[Applause]
you're an Irishman you think these
people accept you'll why are you saying
like that what am I saying cool quit
you're saying cool hwhip yes I'm saying
cool quit on the age cool cool cool cool
[Applause]
[Applause]
do what what should I do
I don't know I feel the need the need
for speed
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's
I'm able to do Sean Connery oh yeah you
could fight sometimes I would call up my
agent and say hello this is Sean Connery
to a tomato and I'd immediately get
through yeah do you do it dragon is back
he is Christopher finished business a
voice that there isn't I mean obviously
it's put through treatments and things
but actually yes it sounds very like
what you did
oh god George did you guys beating
faster
as Clint Eastwood described as as you
hit a few marks you say a few lines
what's the problem when you're in a
Clint Eastwood movie you don't even know
the camera is rolling and you just hear
over your shoulder all right go ahead
[Laughter]
sometimes you doing some pretty hot
stuff and you just keep doing it until
you hear him say that's enough of that
and then you move on you're on to the
next setup it's intimidating as hell
please record your personal greeting to
end recording so you press zero zero
zero zero zero is that one I start yeah
I don't know who you are I don't have
any money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a very specific set of skills for
somebody like you but my daughter go now
I will find you
[Applause]
[Music]